yoth monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur vu ses règles et ne pas
un jeu indé il ya trois versions du jeu
on est sur scène tu as von poehl start
works est parti ils ont sorti cette
version à l'occasion de noël à 1
malheureusement c'est plus noël et on
est les seuls trucs qui joue dans les
séries finales pour doit juste nettoyées
un peu partout voilà comme ça on me
demandez pas pourquoi les gens sur les
murs j'en sais foutrement rien laisser
de d'ailleurs aucun sens
ouais d'accord qu'on étale plus le truc
autre chose les gallois qui succède
est-ce que tu aimerais faire action
ajusté du monde j'entends pas est ce que
tu es prêt à la une à la deux à trois
aspects tout ça que je voulais faire ça
ici elle dépitée mais tu vas tu rentres
un peu et tu brûles tu prétention terre
peut tacher bon ok c'est que çà ou là on
a un gros délire là un sceau rouge deux
sauts ça suffit d'accord donc je suppose
que c'est avec ça qu'ils aiment falloir
nettoyer le parterre à plus tard des
phonèmes à chaque fois et on peut pas
faire une technique un peu plus bourrin
octobre voilà comme ça comme ça on a
bien partout peut bien tout laver [ __ ]
ça ne marche pas c'est ta faute plus
tard aller non accepte son sort
ouais c'est pas du corps aussi que y
aller à l'essai le bon ok c'est que ça
oh oui ce que veut pas s'en servir
non alors maintenant si je leur mets là
mais revient n'ai pas peur accepte son
sort accepte son sort
bon ni quelle [ __ ] mais quel travail à
merde je marchais dans le sang gicle
partout plutôt que tu es suivi le pied
levé qui marche comme ça toi bonjour une
baguette yoplait une baguette et c'est
quoi ces de serpillière vous gagnez une
serpillière comme ça une serbie poulpe
ah merde l'ol est plus propre du touquet
ce qu'on peut leur donner what may est
faite homme et je dois pas changer l'eau
douce on vous donne un bras quoi pas
très bien mais j'accepte tu es là pour
nettoyer les quads ans tout mon gars on
vous dirait qu'on peut voir l'avenir
dans l'aube
à berne et si vous nous donnez un bras
ah bah voilà je suis dégouté je voulais
mon bras moi mon dieu qu'est ce qui
s'est passé avec ce petit homme est ce
qu'il est et ce qui les tient bon le
petit protégé
enfin protégés il vient de se bouffer le
mur de manière très violente
hop je te fera cadeau tu veux pas de
cadeau je t'offre un cadeau je t'offre
au galop daniel tapenade cadeau à qu'est
ce qu'on fait de lui et se compose la le
moment nul
stop stop on est censé tout ranger là
dedans elle est c'est parti
bien trouvé notre au prince à lui seul
pourra tout à l'égout
ah c'est vrai que ça va ça alors je vais
te rendre service en reposant ta tête
sur ton corps va te faire qu'est ce donc
mais avec mais c'est n'importe quoi qui
sait que ça ne va pas trop une sorte d'
éléphant et sur vous et la scène du roi
lion ah ah merde progression faisait la
scène du 2 me roy lyon
[Musique]
quoi bc il est comme dans le dessin
animé où tu croyais t'en sortir bien là
mon bébé vient à la papa va s'occuper de
toi m'a pas vraiment bien s'occuper de
toi regarde au plat up et voilà papa
s'est occupée comment as tu pu et la
carotte les systèmes faut pas laisser de
traces faut pas laisser de trace non au
bar celle là elle est non voilà mais non
énorme et michael moore
mais allez vous faire [ __ ] j'en
appelle aux pouvoirs du dieu du saut à
skis de descente
bon dit qu'elle va pouvoir des toits et
tous au plat mais non mais [ __ ] de
suite que ça s'il vous plaît nettoie la
table aussi parce que oui dans ce jour
d'étoilés table et tout circuit hier n'y
a pas de problème quoi tu peux 1 à do
what you're gonna do you wanna get what
for you reach qu'est ce qui se passe là
dedans que ça va nous laver les côtes un
peu sur en dedans je veux blâmer les
quote ok c'est un bac pour mettre les
déchets de danse ça tu acceptes ton sort
ou y'a quoi ici nickel donc j'espère
dans un jeu où tu fais le ménage et toi
bien non mais les mecs sérieux et c'est
par un homme de ménage qu'il faut la ccl
22 quoi qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici
l'animal n'avait rien fait que ces
retrouve au milieu de lutte est acharnée
c'est ce qu'on a eu assez scandaleux
c'est pas toi que je parle est assez
scandaleux et là y'a quoi ça lui un tu
faisais tu avec cette arme up a laissé
le châtiment pour toi c'est le châtiment
ses deux tentatives de fuite
alors là tu vois le feu là tu vois bien
tu pourrais m'aider à nettoyer s'te
plaît
aide-moi est deux fois c'est comme ça
que tu t'en fuient leur tour c'est quoi
ce truc guggas à décoder
oh je suis désolé je suis désolé je suis
désolé je suis désolé je dis dans l'oeil
mais tout passe tétouan et les ponts
[ __ ] y'a pas y'a pas une
j'appuie sur trois est ce qu'on appelle
une lingette pour laver les chaussures
pour moi j'ai déjà accompli un exploit
j'ai fait un mètre carré de propre
enfance quoi tu peux vous répondre se
plaît bon je comprends tu as même pas me
parler je comprends mais du mois au
moins complète cm fait tourner tu es mon
seul ami mes amis je les pose sur une
table comme ça je leur offre même des
cadeaux même des bûches
j'aime bien leur faire des bûches dix
combats ici ah oui d'accord au nord il
est de retour non vie tués dont l'oeuvre
est fait de toi et les plaies nettoyer
les plaies maintenant il faut brûler les
bactéries tôt et si je mets une tête le
moyen pas comme ça une jambe
une autre jambe et un bras est ce que la
machine va tout recoller non je vais
tenter de vous sauver les veilles j'ai
tenté ce que je peux faire c'est
l'étoile et plus toyer lui plaît ce qui
à votre avis est il va se passer quelque
chose
tiens tu obligé peur sur un jeu comme
que ça va être très très risqué
non j'ai raté
[ __ ] c'était naze objections qui s'y
fait autour de s'enfuir ni les tumultes
amplifon gare sous marine arabesques à
se bâtir et non pas trop hop on va leur
mettre la radio
s'amuse quand même là dedans ferme beach
non mais pourquoi mais plus les robes
toujours tout ça c'est ta faute
un jeune colonne vertébrale et un bras
le fameux qui essaye actuellement de
nous endormir
[Musique]
j'ai pas ce qui est arrivé mais tu y as
tu un [ __ ] on dirait que je tartine de
beurre un lutin à lait le beurre robe
sur la carotte et on la mort aux arabes
et aux grilles de pin up on attends une
minute et elle est prête à servir sur
une table avec quelques d'assaisonnement
tout de même sinon c'est pas bon et
ensuite on laboure avec tout ce qu'on
aime
et voilà qu est ce qu un esprit
maléfique et dans cette lampe arrête
alors qu on la déguste voilà dans ce cas
je déguste pas mais tu me fais dans ce
perso c'est parti
non non non non non non non non non non
c'est sûr je me suis trompée elle était
très bien s'annonce non non non non non
le budget définitif bon [ __ ] de luton
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette petite vidéo sur twitter avec les
neuf c'est un jeu indé qui a fait
beaucoup parler de lui à sa sortie je
l'avais jamais testé j'avoue que c'était
sacrément what the fuck
on se retrouve bientôt dans une nouvelle
vidéo tu as tout le monde
[Musique]
les faits